okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode
of q a on history of science and
technology
so i see there are a bunch of questions
here that were left over from last time
there was one here from pavel interested
in the evolution of mechanics from
newton
through dalamba to lagrange and so on
i have to admit i don't know that
history as well as i might but uh
let me tell you some things i i do know
about about the history of mechanics
so i mean the first question about
mechanics
is to get even the basics
of how mechanical processes work right
so for example aristotle
who wrote about many things i mean
aristotle was a was a
a huge maker of lists of things you know
animals
forms of argumentation that turned into
logic
also kind of things that are sort of
obvious about the world but should be
written down
like what is the way that uh things
determine
how they should that their how they
should move
and so he had this idea oh i realized
something i'm sorry i just
realized a mistake here which i need to
fix hold on one second
um the uh
okay um in any case the the uh okay
about aristotle so so there were sort of
questions about
what was the basic origin of motion
how did motion work that was the thing
that was thought about in greek times
it's it's really very unobvious
what motion actually is when something
moves from here to there
what's really going on in our model of
physics
we start to have ways to really think
about that
but you know there's this question of do
you take this object
and just put it somewhere else in space
is it the same object
that is being sort of transported in
what coordinates in space it's in
some how space is changing underneath it
or is it somehow that you're recreating
this object at a different point in
space
these are kinds of questions that in the
time of greek philosophers people
thought about and subsequent times they
sort of stopped thinking about those
once there were mathematical
formulations of these things now in our
physics project
we really have to think about this again
but let me not
divert in talking about how this works
in in our
theory of fundamental physics but let me
ask the question
you know when aristotle was trying to
imagine how did motion work
what did he imagine well
for example is the question of why do
things fall
well he said because they they have a
preferred place
in the world and it's kind of in the
down direction so to speak
um he didn't really have a a notion of
forces that caused things to move he
more had this idea that
that it just has a a place it should be
in and that's down
so to speak another thing that was an
issue
for aristotle is if you sort of if you
push things how do they move
in the time of aristotle most things you
might push
you had to kind of keep pushing them to
have them keep on moving
there was lots of friction in most kinds
of systems that people
were looking at at the time there was
probably either a mixture of friction
or there were things like animals that
were sort of moving themselves in ways
that were
yet completely different from the way
that a
sort of purely inanimate object might
work so that was
in in uh in antiquity
and then i think the um uh
there were kinds of questions like how
do you think about
the process of things moving in space
through time
like we we very routinely would make a
um
kind of a plot that shows oh this is the
position
as a function of time but that wasn't
something that was familiar
in antiquity and so i think it was uh
what was it
um rm or us or
orm or resma i don't know how it's
pronounced
that was probably in the what's at the
1200s or something
that um people started really uh having
this idea that you could do
the equivalence of sort of plot
something as a function of time
but then it took until
uh well the the sort of the the big
use case for mechanics was
things in the heavens so to speak the um
uh whatever might be going on on earth
it was clear that there was some
inexorable motion that was happening in
the heavens
you know planets would move from here to
there the babylonians certainly had
sort of empirical models of how the
planets moved
that seemed to be quite mathematical in
character
um and there was sort of the question of
okay so how did the motion of the
heavens really work
are planets moving around and so on and
there are variety of kinds of theories
for that
and the theories tended to be uh more
kind of explanatory theories there were
things like uh
uh you know ptolemy had this whole
development of epicycles where it's kind
of like a
a whole elaborate kind of gear-like
mechanism
that was moving the planets around and
then kepler sort of updated that to be
more
some something where was thinking about
kind of
platonic solids um that were kind of
more mathematical in character
they could kind of move on each other to
reproduce the
the uh the observed distances and
motions of planets
um and uh kepler also observed these
sort of empirical laws of motion that
turned into kepler's laws
that were things about um you know equal
areas are uh
uh swept out in equal times and the
three halves law for the relationship of
um
uh the the the the power law of the
relationship between uh orbital period
and um uh and distance from from the sun
and so on
and so these these were things that were
known but were not really understood it
was like okay yes
i mean kepler had really wanted things
to work out with all
of these platonic solids sliding on each
other in a very perfect
uh kind of uh mathematical way had
actually observed
these empirical laws about uh
distances and and periods of planets and
so on
but then i think the uh very important
moment in all of this was the galileo
um in probably the 1620s ish
um who kind of
got interested in essentially
mathematicizing
uh things about motion and
in a sense the mathematicization of
things
had uh there were different kinds of
things that have been mathematicized
strangely music
was one of the more mathematicized kinds
of areas
where people knew that the ratio
frequencies of different
notes that would correspond to being
things that were
um in in nice progressions you know the
the the octave
factor of two the the perfect fifth a
factor of uh three halves things like
this
these numerical ratios were known that
was known since the pythagoreans
actually
um and that one could kind of sort of
physicalize those ratios by knowing that
was
the uh relative distance of strings that
would be plucked and
the relative lengths of strings that
will be plucked and so on
but in any case the there was sort of
the question of could you mathematicize
things about motion and i think the the
one of the important things that galileo
discovered
was the the uh the quadratic law
for the relationship between distance
and uh
acceleration so this this idea
that uh you know you drop something um
how it goes
uh uh the the velocity increases
linearly with time more or less
and the um
and the uh um the the distance goes up
like the square
of the time now again galileo
would do things like uh you know
famously drop
two balls from the tower of pisa which
was at that time
i guess the tallest building other than
maybe the pyramids and things that was
um was out and about in the world but he
dropped these um
uh these balls and uh observed that
yes it didn't matter what the balls were
made of they landed at the same time
now of course that wouldn't really it
was that depended on
all kinds of features of air resistance
and so on if he had actually done what
um i think the later astronaut did on
the moon
of dropping you know feather and a rock
at the same time and seeing that on the
moon where there's no atmosphere
they they drop it with the same
acceleration
galileo wasn't really able to do that
experiment because
uh air resistance would cause his
feather to
to fall at a vastly different rate than
his rock
but any case galileo kind of observed
this sort of mathematical
relation between uh uh
distance and time and so on that was
this quadratic law
um i think uh galileo
was sort of motivated to
to define kind of universal laws of
motion by the observation
in 1608 of moons of jupiter which kind
of gave the idea that well
yes there might be sort of global laws
of mechanics
that might work uh out there
in the you know satellites of jupiter as
they work
in kind of uh the the motion of the
earth
as they might work on in terrestrial
kinds of settings
but i think the um there remained all
kinds of
things that were not well explained
um and
the um notably the motion of comets
was one that was not well explained but
i think the thing that began to happen
with galileo was this idea
that things that were put in motion
might stay in motion
and things and sort of an idea of what
might be going on
roughly with uh with things falling and
you know was that really an
aristotle story or was there something
where there was something like a force
that was making things things fall
newton really cleaned all of this stuff
up in 1687 in his you know mathematical
principles of natural philosophy
book um and uh i think
he was the one who really started to
think about um
well his his laws of motion for example
which said things like
a thing not acted on by external forces
will remain in
its state of motion well in other words
if you just sort of start something
going
it will just keep going at the same
velocity forever
and that will have been something
completely unobvious to somebody like
aristotle because
just wasn't an experience he had he
didn't have you know an air hockey table
he didn't have these kinds of things
where where things would just stay in
their state of motion
they would tend to come to rest through
friction and things like that
and also aristotle didn't have the idea
of
thinking of gravity as a force like a
force that you can make by pushing on
things and so on
but by the time of newton he'd sort of
unified the idea of force
the force of gravity the force of you
pushing on something and so on
and his laws of motion you know force
equals mass times acceleration
being second law important sort of law
of motion
that was at some level a definition of
the notion of force
and to say that is what force
does is it changes the acceleration the
state of motion of an object in in just
that way
well having figured that out he then had
to work out how does this force
idea relate to gravity and that's
when he came up with this universal law
of gravitation that the
force of gravity is just the product of
the masses divided by the square of the
distance between two objects
and then tried to calculate things based
on that
uh that uh force law for gravity he
didn't have force laws for other kinds
of things i mean
hook for example contemporary of newtons
i don't think they got on particularly
well
um the uh uh was the one responsible for
for example the forced law for springs
hooke's law
that said that the force associated with
uh a spring would be based on
its the extension of the spring i i have
to say i think
it's said i don't know if this is
entirely true that that um
uh newton had this comment
you know if i have seen far it is
because i have stood on the shoulders of
giants
and i think the footnote to that was
hook happened to be
very short in stature kind of what would
be in those days called the dwarf
and newton was kind of it said
kind of tweaking at um at hook by making
that comment
of course that comment has become
enshrined in things like modern patent
law
as the otsod principle you know on the
shoulders of giants
principle about uh when is there
something really new in the world or or
not
but um in any case i think um
newton uh you know his sort of uh
uh top sort of force law was the was his
universal law of gravitation
then the question was okay so we've got
these laws of motion we've got now this
force law at least for gravity
how do we actually work out how things
move
well newton for example tried to work
out the motion of the moon
and he got the wrong answer and uh
it turns out that working out
the sort of common motions of the sun
the earth and the moon
that's a very difficult problem it
wasn't a problem that was really
solved uh well really solved well enough
to predict eclipses and things properly
wasn't really solved until uh about a
hundred years ago
um and with even more precision not
until even more recently than that
um but uh in the time of
of newton one of the questions was okay
so we have these equations we have these
laws of motion
how do we then compute what's actually
going to happen and
that became a great interest and in
particular
the problem the three body problem
particularly the earth moon sun problem
became sort of a central problem of
mathematical physics
through the 1800s for example if you had
asked people what
what is what are you aspiring to to do
with mathematical physics
the answer would probably been solve the
three-body problem
so that was so there were there were a
lot of questions about how you would do
that
but i would say there were a couple of
other trends in the in the theory of
mechanics
another big trend was understanding
rigid bodies
so understanding things like cops tops
are very complicated very messy to
understand
and there was a whole tradition um i
don't know i particularly know the
british tradition in this
in this respect of sort of the working
out the motions of
of rigid bodies again that was something
that happened i would say particularly
in the 1800s
and these things like the poll holds and
the herbal hoads
and all these kinds of different axes
that represented the
the the possible um the ways to
parametrize
the motion of a rigid body like a top
that was that was sort of another trend
was the whole rigid body mechanics
business
now there were people who tried to
streamline the treatment of mechanics
and i think the the dalamba
uh lagrange um
uh these were people who were concerned
with
how do you take kind of
the the kind of the the basic
mathematical
infrastructure that newton had defined
for mechanics
and how do you make that be something
that is more streamlined
and amenable to more uh more effective
calculation i think the um
uh the thing that um uh
that caused to be invented was sort of a
mathematical structure of things like
lagrangians
which are a way of a way of sort of
generalizing this thing where newton was
working out sort of
all of the different coordinates that
had to be dealt with in a mechanical
system kind of
each one separately whereas in
lagrangians and later hamiltonians
things like this one was able to have a
more streamlined approach to those kinds
of things
now i would say that again a big
motivation from all of this was
celestial mechanics
the theory of the motion of planets and
there were a lot of different
things that were developed for the for
the sake of doing that um
things like poisson series um
in a sense what was being done was there
were these equations they were really
hard to solve
i mean newton for example uh commented
on think of thinking about kind of the
motion of planets
uh he was sort of confused by their
difficulty and he was
made some comment about how um uh
you know you can in principle work out
all where the planets go
but he said working out the details of
these motions
exceeds uh he said if i'm not mistaken
the force of any human mind in other
words god can move the planets
as the planets move according to
newton's laws but no human mind can work
out how that motion will work
to me that has a very interesting
resonance with the idea of computational
irreducibility
that i've spent many years developing
this notion that
even though you know the rules by which
the system operates
it can still be sort of irreducibly hard
to compute
what the system will do now
computational irreducibility is
is is framed in terms of our modern
notions of computation a little bit
different from what newton talked about
because newton was dealing with
with uh continuous variables and real
numbers and things
whereas now we have sort of a better way
to parametrize
sort of the amount of effort that needs
to be spent on computation
and now that we think we understand
something about how fundamental physics
works
we know that that sort of effort of
computation is the one that's being done
by our universe
rather than this kind of idea that
newton had that that there can be a
precise
position that can be of any number of
digits of precision
for things but any case i think the um
uh sort of a a motivating
force in the development of mechanics
through the 1800s was
the idea of celestial mechanics
particularly the three body problem
um there were also things like the uh
the calculation
of of the motion of planets so famously
um uranus had been discovered by
herschel
with an actual telescope then neptune
was discovered
by well adams and laverie were the two
people who were kind of the
the competitors for that discovery but
um that was a discovery a theoretical
discovery that was a discovery from
looking at the perturbations
to other planets and saying let's
calculate based on newton's laws
um what what else should be going on is
there in fact another planet involved
if you look at what adams and le verrier
did
their work is this giant
algebraic computation of uh you know
what would the motion of planets be
based on the position based on there
being another planet and where would
that other
planet be and eventually people look for
it and they found the planet
in the position where it was predicted
to be it was a big sort of success of
theoretical science
a big successive kind of newtonian
paradigm
by the way if you ask sort of what
happened to the three body problem
what happened was uh by about
um 1900 it was becoming clear that there
was sort of a fundamental limitation
on solving the three-body problem i mean
there were things that were invented
to understand the three-body problem for
example ori poincare invented topology
to understand the possible solutions to
the three-body problem the sort of
parameterization
of the different possible solutions the
three-body problem
but um it had become a little bit
clearer that there could be sort of
impossibility results i mean from
galwa from the 1830s or so
it uh emerged the idea that
another thing people have been working
on for a long time was you have a
quadratic equation there's a quadratic
formula that was known to the
babylonians
you have a cubic equation that was
discovered with great fanfare in i guess
the 1400s by
particularly around cardano and people
like that
that there was a formula for the cubic
equation there was a formula for the
quartic equation discovered around the
same time
but then would there be a formula for
the quintic equation
well people worked on that for a long
time and then gawa
his work showed that no at least if you
wanted to represent it in terms of
algebraic
numbers things like you know cube roots
and fifth roots and so on
there wasn't a formula for the solution
to a quantum equation in those terms
and so people got a little bit used to
the idea that it might be impossible
to compute something and so when towards
the end of the 1800s it became clear
that the three-body problem
didn't have uh solutions at least in
terms of
of these kinds of um uh algebraic
expressions and so on the
official term there are no algebraic
constants of the motion
other than the ones that that were
already obvious and known
um that that kind of killed off the
notion that somebody was going to
magically quote solve the three-body
problem and and people kind of lost
interest in that
and and eventually it became clear you
actually have to do
actual computations uh to work out um
the um uh the motion of things and and
you know these computations
are pretty complicated and uh when
people started having to you know fly
spacecraft and
and figure out you know exactly how
should you navigate to the moon and
things
it became quite important to know in
more detail how to do these celestial
mechanics computations
but uh uh that was sort of very much in
the end going back to
sort of the original equations of newton
and a lot of the kind of
um uh the sort of the the the uh the the
the cool tricks
for how one would solve particular
equations in particular cases and
particular
kinds of series and so on uh that uh
increasingly
that has become irrelevant and it's
really just to go back to the equations
and solve them type
type story um and it matters a lot
what you know the motion of outer
planets and things has a surprisingly
big effect on even
things like the tides on earth they're
affected by things like the motion of
jupiter and so on and
are hard to compute but in terms of the
history of mechanics
um uh from a little bit longer ago
the other sort of strand of mechanics
was the development of things like fluid
mechanics and rigid body
and solid mechanics um there's uh
there's a notion of um uh
the the question was if you want to
describe
the motion of point particles that's one
thing if you want to describe
rigid bodies that's another thing if you
want to just
describe the deformation of of bodies
under stress you know what what how much
strain how much deformation is there
when you put a certain stress on an
object how does that all work
um that led to things like young's
modulus and um
other kinds of ideas uh in the in the
area
of of um
solid mechanics and so on then there was
the question of when
when things flow uh things about fluid
mechanics
and that led in the end to the
navier-stokes equations which were in
the
mid-1800s i think um uh
those were were partial differential
equations kind of
kind of the development was you know
newton invented calculus
to to deal with kind of understanding
the effect of his
his laws because basically
uh the when you work out the
acceleration of something
you have to figure out if you know the
instantaneous acceleration of a thing
what consequence does that have for the
position of the thing
and well yes it requires doing a couple
of integrals
and that's what newton had to figure out
and
what his mechanics was really based on
ordinary differential equations
differential equations
where you have specific discrete
variables and you're looking at the
dependence of their changes on each
other
what came in more like the 1700s to
1800s
was the idea of looking at uh
things where partial differential
equations where you would have
the the rate of flow of a fluid at every
possible position
and um then knowing how the rate of flow
of a fluid at every possible position
affects its rate of flow at other
positions uh for example
euler came up with the euler equations
which are
description the sort of first level of
description of fluid flow
when one doesn't have to deal with
viscosity the kind of analog of friction
in fluids um but so then this
idea of dealing with partial
differential equations much more
mathematically complicated
even today many aspects of partial
differential equations really elude us
in terms of the mathematics that they
involve
but that was sort of a a big necessary
development
to get to continuum mechanics mechanics
of solids mechanics of fluids
things like that and i think um
the sort of a a part of that whole
development
was the introduction of the notion of
fields uh
sort of a question of what when when you
have a magnet
and it will make iron filings line
themselves up in a certain way
what's causing that how do you think
about that process
and i guess michael faraday who was not
really of a
of a particularly mathematical tone of
mind
was the one who really came up with this
idea of well you can think about it as
being a magnetic field
this thing that sort of is a is a
defines this abstract notion of its of
the effect of magnetism
at every point in space for example it's
an abstract
thing which you can then see the effects
of in the in the positions of iron
filings and so on
once this idea of fields had come in one
could kind of
merge these notions that came from
continuum mechanics
and uh start thinking about these fields
as things described by partial
differential equations you could say
what was the magnetic field at this
point what was the vector that
represents
the sort of magnetic effect at this
point and you could describe that as a
field
represented with partial differential
equations that whole
process of doing that was originally
very notationally messy and so on
that notation got significantly cleaned
up by maxwell
in the james clerk maxwell and probably
the 1880s or so
eventually he wrote a textbook about
electrodynamics he introduced maxwell's
equations
which are sort of vector analysis
equations you know
divergence of the electric field equals
you know it's proportional to the
the charge density things like this and
a thing he still had to deal with
sort of the individual components the x
component the y component z
what really cleaned that up was the
introduction of vectors
and then later sort of coordinate free
notation but that had to wait until
well into the 20th century to really
really get properly developed
but so the kind of uh
overall i would say arc of development
of mechanics
there was sort of that from newton there
was kind of this idea of forces
as an abstract thing that you could
think of
as something that you could attribute
motion to
much later the idea of fields as sort of
the
the carriers of the source of forces and
things
um and then in terms of the sort of
mathematical infrastructure
there was kind of the idea of you have
these ordinary differential equations
later partial differential equations to
represent continuum kinds of things
and then sort of the the whole question
of well
given all these equations you know how
do you actually go ahead and solve
them and sort of a whole series of
of stacks of kind of mathematical
infrastructure
appropriate for solving those equations
and ways to essentially package
features of the solutions of those
equations and all the different
components
that were being represented in those
equations packaged them together
in um in different ways and that's
that's at least a a rough outline of um
history of mechanics well up until the
20th century
when we hit the 20th century we start
hitting things about relativity
general relativity quantum mechanics um
and then the advent of the the use of
computers
in studying mechanical systems which is
sort of a separate story i i think i
i maybe left out one piece to this which
is
um uh statics uh you know one of the
things that was very big
in the um uh particularly in the
sort of post-industrial revolution um
but uh well yeah around that time
was the um uh the development of um
a lot of mechanical structures so it's
like how are you gonna work out whether
this bridge was going to hold
up how were you going to like gustav
eiffel for example with his
uh you know his big demo of bridge
building that was
stuck upwards in the eiffel tower um the
you know how are you going to figure out
that the eiffel tower wasn't going to
fall down well you had to do
a bunch of statics static mechanical
calculation
and so that was another branch of this
whole business that was the
the idea of dynamics of the motion of
things and differential equations and so
on
and then there was statics which was a
story of sort of
vectors of force and how those will be
arranged and a lot of kind of um
of work um a lot of particularly french
mathematicians involved in working out
um kind of the uh the theory of of how
all that stuff works and the
you know how sort of forces uh what what
turned into
thinking about vectors although that
wasn't the way they were originally
presented
um so that was another sort of whole
branch of um
of mechanics uh later on that sort of
merged
with dynamics as people started to think
about well what happens when you deform
the eiffel tower
um there's one thing to figure out
statically how do you keep the eiffel
tower from falling down there's another
you know when the wind puts force on the
eiffel tower
and it changes as the gusts come through
and so on
um what effect does that have on on the
um
on the members of the eiffel tower
okay long answer that
well let's see question here
uh
[Music]
um
okay
okay
all sorts of questions here all right
there's one from ein here
why was it the europeans who created
modern mathematics
and not the chinese chinese obviously
had a head start
uh why don't we use chinese characters
instead of the latin alphabet
oh boy well it's it's a little hard to
do these what-if
discussions of history but i can say a
few things
i think one of the things that really
struck me as i as i tried to understand
the history of mathematics
is that various kinds of notational
issues really slow down the progress of
mathematics
so for example uh roman numerals
they are fine ways to represent
individual numbers
you know you want to represent 14 it's x
iv
etc but one of the things that
seems like it's a triviality is the
things that are being used to represent
numbers are letters
and that means that if you want to
somehow introduce the idea of an
unknown for an algebraic variable
in an equation it's like how you can do
that you've got these letters and you've
got other letters i should say that when
euclid
um was writing his his elements of
geometry
he did use letters to represent
unknown things he used letters to
represent things like angles
but somehow when you wanted to combine
those to make an algebra
to sort of combine the idea of actual
concrete numbers
with unknown things that was really
tough to do
in the way that people had set up things
like uh roman numerals
by the way greek numerals worked the
same way i mean in in uh
in greek times the numbers were
represented actually directly by letters
of the alphabet so
you know one was alpha two was beta
three was gamma and so on
i mean i'm i'm fond of telling a story
about that which is
the in greek times the the successive
numbers
were represented by successive letters
in their alphabet
problem was some letters went out of
circulation and so i forget what it is
maybe 60 or something
is represented by a sampy which is a
character that kind of
went out of circulation after the
earlier period of
of uh in greece but but nevertheless
they had burnt
in the the uh those characters
as part of their their numbering system
but i think one of the things that
probably [ __ ] the progress
of algebra was this thing that you
couldn't really distinguish
kind of the numbers from things that
were like what euclid had referred to as
unknown so to speak what
euclid had used as unknowns which were
represented by letters they all sort of
got tangled together
when uh hindu arabic numerals came to
the west
which really happened from people like
leonardo fibonacci in 1200
and 1210 or around that time 1205 i
think
was his lieber abachi the book of the
abacus that introduced
kind of hindu arabic numerals to the
merchants
in in italy and elsewhere um
the uh once you had hindu arabic
numerals
that were really different from letters
that
got you to more start to be able to
think about or we can have a letter that
stands for numbers and so on
and i think it was the development then
of
uh some of the notation for mathematics
and starting fourteen hundreds fifteen
hundreds
to sixteen hundreds that really allowed
sort of
the the the streamlined mathematical
science to get going
you know the uh the the multiplication
sign that was invented by a person
called william outread
who's also was the person who invented
the slide rule
and various people like leibniz
commented
using the x for multiplication is really
stupid people will con
confuse that with an x written out as
a letter of course he was right about
that but nevertheless
the notation stuck but i think
in um
uh the question of
of of why things developed
in the west and not in china in terms of
the development of mathematics
i don't know for sure um i think
that um there were some things that
definitely came from china
that were uh important parts of the
story of mathematics but
but well let me let me uh talk about a
few of the influences so
i think a lot of mathematics came out of
ancient babylon
babylon the babylonian uh
babylonian period was the time when you
know cities were first getting going
people had to streamline a lot of kinds
of things they had to have much more
organized ways to represent i don't know
areas of land weights and measures
things like that
that drove a lot of development of
mathematics
and uh people like pythagoras
no doubt learnt things from ancient
babylon and probably spent time in
ancient babylon probably euclid as well
the the you know a lot of that tradition
of mathematics
came from babylon and so that was there
was one area
where a lot of mathematics originated
one of the things that
one sees is that the time scale
for mathematics to diffuse around the
world is comparatively short
possibly because particularly in those
days merchants were the ones who really
were the
were the main users of mathematics and
merchants traveled
and so you know if somebody knew about
this kind of method for doing a
calculation of interest
well that merchant might uh might be
traveling off to some other country
and would spread that information and so
you see kind of the diffusion of of
knowledge
about mathematical kinds of things being
comparatively rapid
on the time scale of of of the of the
sort of birth and death of civilizations
but there were a few things that we know
or very likely uh came from sort of more
chinese traditions so one of them was
uh the invention of binary numbers was
probably something that came
from the iching um where there's this
these hexagrams that are basically the
representation
of uh of binary numbers of different
possibilities and so on
um that was probably missionaries uh
going to china uh probably learnt about
that
and that's how for example leibniz
probably found out about the idea of
binary
um in the uh in the mid to late 1600s
but um i think the development
of uh the sort of the the big driver for
a lot of that early mathematical
development uh was
was merchants and commerce and so on and
i don't know exactly how that
played out um you know there were places
where that was really
uh in in full swing
particularly around venice and places
like that and and
and so on and later in london and so on
um
i i don't know how that played out in
other parts of the world so i don't know
whether that driver
existed there for sort of mathematical
development
in terms of uh
you know i think it's it's always an
interesting question what
leads different kinds of development
to happen in different parts of the
world
and completely not happen in other parts
of the world and sometimes
there are surprisingly minor issues
like do your numbers uh are your numbers
distinct from your letters and so on
that are important um and that you know
affect whether this particular thing
happens to get discovered there or not
then there are more cultural kinds of
things like
uh is there anybody who's in a position
to just sort of hang out and think about
stuff
or is there a reason uh to
is there a driver whether it's commerce
or or military kinds of things that's a
driver for various kinds of
technological development
um and does that how does that play out
in different kinds of cultures
so i think those are the things that
that seem to affect this
i mean it's
it is interesting that um um
uh well there are different kinds of um
of development uh for example one that i
was struck by recently it's just a weird
thing
the development of mathematical logic in
the um
early 20th century there's a whole bunch
of people involved in this and i've
happened to have recently been
researching a bunch of them and a bunch
of them i i thought oh that person's an
american i don't know anything more
about them
it turns out there's this region in
basically uh eastern
poland and western ukraine and
in a first approximation i would say
solidly two-thirds and i haven't done
this properly quantitatively
of the people who were involved in the
in the sort of major developments of
mathematical logic
in the uh first part of the 20th century
solidly probably two-thirds of those
people were born
in this fairly small sort of corridor
in that part of the world they didn't
have any interaction with each other
there
they didn't even go to school there in
many cases but it's a really strange
thing
that uh it seems like there's this sort
of coincidence
of people who got interested in the sort
of formalization of mathematical logic
who happen to come from that part of the
world i can't claim to explain this
at all but uh it's just an observation
that i that i recently made
um and it's it's uh you know i think one
has to realize
if one looks in modern times at sort of
what happens in different parts of the
world
uh you know the movies get made in
hollywood the uh
you know the cars used to get made in
detroit but probably no longer
the um uh you know the the tech stuff is
sort of happening
in silicon valley and you know et cetera
et cetera et cetera there are these
sort of regional concentrations of
activity
that develop in the world and uh there
are you know typically there are things
that drive those about
sort of the fact that it becomes a
tradition in that area
to do these kinds of things and you know
you go to silicon valley
and uh you'll go to your average
starbucks and everybody will be talking
about you know
the latest startup that you're that
they're doing and so on
um you know in um hollywood you know
it's pitching a script
these kinds of things it's you know
these regional areas
develop where where there's sort of a
lot of energy around a particular
line of developments and i suspect
that's the thing that one has seen in
the history of
of science and mathematics as well and
different places got that or didn't get
that
um and uh uh that's that's the best i
can say and it's sort of a um
um uh uh
you know a comment on that yeah comment
here that pascal's triangle was known in
china before europe yeah
i think that's true and i think that the
um uh
pascal's triangle is is sort of closely
related to all of these sort of
combinatorial
enumerations of things which which is
this sort of the eachine story
i mean one has to be a little bit
careful sometimes
with these questions of such and such a
thing was known
in such and such a place really really
really early
because once you know it it's kind of
easy to go back
and say well that thing was really
sort of a sign of going in that
direction or this direction i mean
having been involved in a few things
that have sort of turned into history of
science myself
in in um the you know going back and
saying did one really understand this at
that time
well i can say i didn't really
understand it you know going back i can
see that yes i actually did figure this
thing out
in some sense but i didn't really
understand the point of it at that time
i think that's a difficult thing
projecting back in history and it's true
for example both with indian and chinese
uh science that the dating of things is
often very difficult and not known
within a course of many centuries it's
it's not known when
when important works were produced and
so on
and so that that creates difficulty in
in this
and this very fact that there's such
rapid diffusion
of knowledge around the world also
confuses things i mean one of the
examples of that that
that i'm familiar with is there's a
particular maze pattern
that um you that it's not clear where it
originated
um it's it's uh uh it's something you
see
on on um on coins and things from the
island of crete and so at different
times i think people said it was the
logo of the city of troy
it was a map of the uh of the labyrinth
of the minotaur on crete
it was various kinds of things that have
been designed that that labyrinth was
designed by
uh daedalus i guess uh was one of the
sort of mythical statements and so this
was the
the maze designed by daedalus to uh sort
of
uh uh hide the minotaur or whatever and
um
the uh you know a variety of kind of
mythology about this maze shows up
but what's interesting is this maze
pattern
it's a very specific maze pattern uh
shows up
all over the world including in places
like south america
uh including in uh well by by uh uh
you know by a thousand a.d it's you know
on the floor of the um
of the cathedral at chartres things like
this it's it's um
uh it shows up very very broadly a very
specific and arbitrary thing shows up
very broadly
and that kind of gives you a sense of
the diffusion rates
of these these sort of mathematical
kinds of of concepts
and so that's another thing that makes
dating things difficult
now i think when it comes to
questions there are
particular traditions that exist so for
example
in indian kind of mathematical tradition
uh there were things people cared about
like one of the things that
people cared about a lot was prosidy
kind of the
the um the scanning of uh um
the sort of setting to music of words
and
the way that sort of the lengths of um
of words scan and things like poetry
and there were questions that came up
like uh you know could you enumerate
the possible forms of prosidy and things
and so that
presumably led to the development of
fibonacci numbers
way way before fibonacci in india
and there were also things like for
example as a person called panini
who developed a grammar of sanskrit
and that grammar of sanskrit looked a
lot like
modern kind of production rules for
for representing sort of uh recursively
representing grammars
by the way here's a piece of history
that i only learned yesterday
so i've been very confused about um
uh the origin of um uh
um grammar that um
of this idea of representing grammars
recursively
saying uh you can
say a sentence is composed of
blah blah this phrase this phrase this
phrase and those phrases are in turn
composed of this and this and this and
having these rules by which you can
construct
a grammar like that well in 1956
two completely different traditions or
so they seemed
originated one was the tradition of
generative
grammar from noam chomsky and so on and
the other was the tradition of
of what became called bacchus nowa form
uh
which so generative grammar was a way of
describing human languages bacchus nowa
form
was a way of describing computer
languages like things like fortran and
so on
um and those two things both developed
in 1956
and i had not understood how could this
have happened
were they independent were they
connected and so on i asked noam chomsky
once that question
um and uh he didn't really give a
definite answer to that
um i didn't know you know which came
first degenerative grammar come first
did um uh did bacchus now form come
first
well i was recently studying a person
called emel post
who was a person who worked in
mathematical logic
um particularly well
in several periods around 1920 then
around again around 1940
um emil post invented these things he
called
production systems which were
essentially string rewriting systems
and turns out i think both those
traditions in 1956
came out of what post had done in
uh that he originally done actually in
1920
but didn't really publish properly until
about 1940
and then they sort of got ingested into
textbooks
around 1950 and i think that's where
both of those traditions came from they
both came from post-production systems
and uh uh that that clears up a mystery
for me because i was very
very confusing to me the both would have
originated then now having said that
they originated then
the idea for sort of recursively
specified grammars
appears to have been present in the work
of panini and
we don't know exactly when maybe around
uh a
couple of centuries bc a couple of
centuries a.d i'm not sure
um in india um working on the grammar of
sanskrit
so that's a it's a case where where um
uh there was sort of an origination and
i haven't really studied
in tremendous detail what panini did i
it is my impression
that it really was a sort of slam dunk
example
of yes there are these recursive
specifications of grammars
i'm i'm aware i had looked at one point
about some
latin grammars uh notably lucretius for
example
uh famously mentioned in the first
century a.d has this very nice statement
that
maybe the way that atoms form things in
the world he had the idea that atoms
were the way that
mata was built up that atoms form things
in the world
much as grammar specifies that
letters and words should be formed into
sentences and so on which was a very
very nice kind of way of thinking about
formalism but that kind of suggested
that there was a very organized form of
grammar in those times and there were
grammar books
but i don't think there was the same
kind of recursive notion
of constructing grammars that that
existed then
the i think um
let's see uh
okay the rbs mentions that um
uh math competitions might have been a
thing but
i think not because the bizarre thing is
that many of the people involved in
mathematical logic you know
left at age four and things like this so
i think it's more
if anything a cultural tradition than
than it is anything for example to do
with education there
uh all right i should i should wrap this
up in a moment
i think maybe we've got um maybe i could
try
one more question
um
[Music]
there's a question from d0 here
let's see it's a question of there are
obvious problems with peer-reviewed
academic research
is there a way that science was
developed in the past that we can learn
from
where we were better at sort of
reviewing science
well you know it's a funny thing if you
look at
the early scientific journals so
scientific journals probably the first
scientific journal
was procedures of the royal society
people like hook were involved in that
um and uh halle was involved in that
this was in the late 1600s
if you look at the papers that people
wrote
in the presence the royal society the
early issues of it
they read very much like blog posts
today they're really kind of interesting
and funny
you know they're things like i went up
this mountain at um
very early in the morning and it was
very cold and
i observed this green flash when the sun
came up
and meanwhile you know the badgers were
running around on the ground or whatever
else
it's very much more telling a story and
um
the the idea of the kind of desiccated
scientific paper
is something there's a much more recent
origin um it also even the notion
that um i mean what what had been the
case
was that these kind of societies and
journals and things
were uh were publishing more like blogs
today
more like the narrative of what was
going on
and there was pretty much if you were a
member of one of those societies you got
to publish in those journals
and uh you got to kind of have the
things that you talked about there
printed up and distributed to people i
think the notion
of um uh kind of scientific journals
where you were just somebody out there
in the world and you sent it in
sent in your papers i think those
existed late
1700s maybe early 1800s but they were
usually associated with a particular
person
that was you know like krell's journal
of mathematics
or sometimes with a particular place a
particular university
and it was like you knew who was
responsible it wasn't
kind of the faceless uh system it was
like
oh i'm gonna send it to so and so and
they're going to publish it
um and i think that this idea you know
as science got bigger
the um the notion that it was all sort
of
a faceless process uh got more prevalent
and the idea that there wasn't sort of
individual responsibility about you know
mr krell or whatever
uh being the one responsible for was
that math paper published or not
the idea that was sort of a collective
decision that was done in a faceless way
that is the phenomenon of the upscaling
of the size of science
pretty much associated with post-world
war
ii period i mean what had happened there
were a lot of weird forces that that
were in play at that time i mean
one of the weirder ones was um this sort
of publishing entrepreneurship
uh in the wake of world war ii um and
particularly as things went into kind of
the sputnik era
of um sort of interest in you know
science being a really important thing
but even after world war ii
it was clear that sort of science was a
a thing of greater national priority
than
people had imagined before and so on and
so there was a
drive to you know let's build up sort of
the science effort
um in different places at universities
or elsewhere
different countries and so on but one of
the sort of entrepreneurial
opportunities that created was
there were all these random journals
that had been published by you know the
the uh the the journal of the lower such
and such
society of of lower you know some small
municipality somewhere or this or that
there were there were a lot a whole
giant sort of patchwork of scientific
journals
and um uh entrepreneurs particularly
robert maxwell
uh was probably the most most famous of
these kind of went around and sort of
bought up these journals
and then went particularly to american
universities and said okay
i have the journal of the uh kind of um
you know i don't know the bratislava you
know mathematical weekly
whatever it was thing you know i'm
publishing this now you
as a an american university library
that wants to be having the best
possibility of doing the best research
you must subscribe to this journal in
order to be current and so
this idea of these giant number of
journals there was a a big kind of
commercial driver of let's have more and
more and more journals
because by golly these american
universities particularly
will pay for subscriptions to all of
these journals and so that became this
vast industry
that that expanded the number of things
that got published to the point
uh so that was one dynamic the other
dynamic that happened was
the sort of uh the the structure of the
the academic system and the ideas about
you know
tenure and the whole systematization of
academic positions
happened that was again a post-world war
ii and then post sputnik
kind of uh phenomenon and that
then needed kind of uh sort of
ways to assess academics and um
uh well there was a chap called gene
garfield i knew him
uh late in his life this person who
invented the science citation index
um which was and his idea was to sort of
understand the network of who cited who
and be able to figure out given that you
found an interesting paper
who would be the people who were
following up on that paper and i used to
use the
the paper versions of the science
situation index to figure out um
uh kind of what were what were the
things
what were the future study of some
particular thing that i found
interesting
i did have the interesting experience in
1983 i was studying cellular automata
and they had had many different names
but i found most of those names
and i looked up pretty much everybody
who'd written a paper about these kinds
of things
ever and i pretty much invited all the
ones who were alive
to a conference at los alamos they'd
never met each other they didn't even
know these other fields existed partly
because
the names were were different and so on
that was that was a lot of fun
but um in any case the the uh the sort
of another driver was this idea
of you know your publish or perish type
idea for academia
i've just pumped out more papers then
there was the whole
i guess it's been in modern times
actually after i've stopped being an
academic
that the whole you know h index and and
uh
citation you know uh where how does how
do your papers fit into the citation
network and so on that that's become
important
but i think this ecosystem of lots of
journals
university libraries had to have them
and then sort of the way of assessing
academics how many times did you publish
this led to the sort of giant system
that becomes very faceless very
institutionalized
and uh i i think that the the more
uh the earlier the earlier way of doing
this when science was much smaller and
it's like
so and so was responsible for deciding
to publish it okay that person's an
idiot
so that was a bad thing but it was a
particular person responsible it wasn't
sort of
the faceless collective that was
responsible and i think
the uh that's to my mind
the the kind of uh you know the the
personal responsibility
of and and the sort of personal branding
of sort of decisions about what gets
to be published in the world i think is
is uh
something that was sort of a good
feature of earlier periods of science
but science
was much smaller and you know one of the
things that happens is when things are
smaller it's actually easier to be
innovative you might think
when there are more people doing stuff
gosh more ideas will come out
but that's one dynamic but the other
dynamic is when the thing is big and
institutionalized
there are structures that say well it's
got to flow in this direction
and if there's something that's not in
the flow we can't deal with that
so so that it becomes actually more
difficult for innovation to happen even
though there are more
sort of potential sources of innovation
so i think uh
you know those are probably the um the
things i think we're returning
with sort of the um uh um
the the sort of the the the the blog
posts of today
um are and you know my efforts to
write about science things i discover
you know i have not
been writing i haven't really written a
a a
pure academic paper since 1986
um and uh i find i i think one of the
things that
is sort of a killer that happened in
some areas of scientific paper writing
is
the kind of don't say why you're doing
it just
uh you know stick to the the most
official sort of facts you can i mean in
mathematics papers
this becomes the you know my my
version of this is the paper starts with
let f be a field
and then just goes blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah why why are we
considering f
that is never mentioned it's just let f
be a field with these properties and now
we work out what consequences that has
that's very different from the style of
kind of the narrative where you're
explaining why are you doing this
and one of the things that's happened in
a bunch of fields of mathematics being
one of them
is that it becomes almost disreputable
to say
why you're doing it to give the meta
information about why you're doing
something
it's like no no just stick to the stick
to the stuff that's the sort of formal
things that happen in the field you know
the other
dynamic that happens in more
experimental fields
there's a a great tendency to not tell
the story
you know what happened to that mouse
nobody's gonna
say this particular mouse uh
stuck its nose in this thing and so it
wasn't didn't have a very happy time and
so when we tested this thing on it that
mouse
didn't test out right and um instead
they're just gonna say
you know the statistical significance of
this is blah
with this number of mice doing this and
that number of mice not doing this
there is no story behind that yet if you
actually knew the story of what had
happened
you it would probably give you a lot
more information it would also to my
mind give you a lot more confidence
and what was really done here you know
there's a lot that can be hidden behind
the you know statistical result xyz
it's like what actually happened you
know one thing that that i've been doing
sort of an experiment recently in in our
physics project particularly is it's a
it's a it's a thing that that's new and
different and i think never been
possible before
it's sort of the fully open science
where kind of
i'm i'm uh posting kind of the notebooks
that i use every day they get posted you
know probably the things i did last
night
already posted um of uh sort of the the
the
actual working notebooks that i've used
uh to to figure out the things i'm
trying to figure out
and we've also been posting kind of
videos of
we've been live streaming some of our
working sessions and i've been posting
videos some of them i
i think are perhaps some a little bit
weird to watch
but uh video work logs i'm calling them
where it's literally i can record for
six hours
completely silent i'm just working on
stuff now
you know is that useful i'm not sure the
one thing i did realize is
if somebody wants to know why does this
number
why is this number three not two in this
document that i've written
in principle you can really drill all
the way down
to see the moment where that number got
written and oh maybe i was confused and
it's wrong or whatever else
but you can really drill all the way
down and see that and that's a level of
transparency
that we've no it's never really been
possible before it's never
and it's something that i think is you
know i'm doing it as sort of an
experiment
um i think it's something one could
argue would be a really good thing for
sort of academics everywhere to think
about doing um because it really gives
you
sort of the full story of you know i
want to know
much of the time you only want to know
tell me just the big conclusion
but if you want to drill down you're
really trying to understand what's going
on
there's there's much more detail and
another thing of course at modern times
is the whole computational language
computational essays
being able to take uh pieces of
computational language you know i'm
routinely doing this
i've just been working on some stuff
that i worked on last in 1991
the the wolfram language code that i
wrote in 1991 still runs today
and i've been using a bunch of it um and
that's that's a really nice thing to be
able to have
uh sort of a live uh actionable
uh computational thing that you can pick
up many years later and use
um i think that's a that's another
feature of modern times that
didn't really exist in the past but i
think perhaps the closest analog it's
not
my necessarily my favorite but um uh
used to be the case that
surgical uh operations were sometimes
done
in operating theaters which were
literally
a place where people could watch the
operation being done
and that was i i don't think that's my
favorite analogy particularly being a
squeamish person that i am
for um uh for my kind of open working
session approach to
to science um and uh
i think that the um uh that that's um
but
but that's uh sort of this this um
uh you know there were some other things
actually of ancient times or
you know a while ago about the way
science was done
i mean uh there were strange kinds of
public events like the the presentation
of the solution to the cubic
equation that was a whole sort of
bizarre
skullduggery included public event
um and that's something that uh
and there were there were sort of public
competitions about ideas and things
which are a little different from what
we see today
i mean i i would say that there were are
was there an analog
of kind of science announced by twitter
i don't know i i think that's um
uh probably not so much i mean there
were the
the societies in london and paris and
places like that
were publishing their weekly um uh
sort of discussions um and so that was
the thing that was happening on a pretty
short time scale there
i think um and there was a lot of
science that was conducted
as a in correspondence between different
kinds of people
that was very email-like i mean by the
time i know when i was studying the
the history of uh charles babbage and
ada lovelace
in london in the 1840s and so on the um
uh there were like 14 mail deliveries
per day
um in london at that time so that's a
that's a pretty good approximation to
kind of email rates
of uh of exchange of ideas um
and so those are a few thoughts but i
think that the
the notion of the sort of uh anonymous
jury of peers peer review idea is is a
comparatively recent notion
um and i think it is a it is one of the
uh probably downsides of the kind of
giant institutionalization of science
um and yes we can probably learn from
earlier periods the more personalized
approach
to sort of taking responsibility for
what's said in science i
i tend to much prefer all right
i think we should probably wrap up here
um
i see a lot of other interesting
questions which i
look forward to addressing another time
so thanks for joining us here
and uh our schedule
is in two weeks at this time we'll do
another
history of science and technology q a in
one week at this time
we're doing the business and innovation
q a although we're thinking moving that
to a uh
possibly uh to a slightly different
platform and that that might change
um the um and uh
i am back to my day job in a minute here
and i'm actually going to be
live streaming a design review of some
wolfram language functionality
at in a few minutes
well thanks for